à quoi ressemble le prince charmant mais
il existe bien sûr il n'y a pas un homme
idéal mais chaque époque et riche des
modèles selon les moeurs et les
représentations de l'homme dans les
médias et des arts jusque dans les
années 70
l'image de l'homme puissant chef de
famille dominant persiste
c'est le seul point d'accord entre ces
femmes en 1974 sur le plateau de
l'émission aujourd'hui madame est ce que
vous croyez que les femmes détestent on
est les âmes abusent de leurs forces à
je ne sais pas pour cette même émission
des hommes ont été interrogés sur leurs
définitions et doit être pas mal bien
balancée et l'homme ridel si on peut
appeler ça c'est quelqu'un qui se prend
d'abord pas au sérieux
physiquement c'est je crois que ça n'a
pas grande importance au fond pas
d'importance mais à partir des années 80
le cinéma et le sport façonne un idéal
masculin musclée plus tôt bronzé et
débarrassée de tous poils pour autant à
écouter ces jeunes femmes en 1983
l'exigence est ailleurs qu'il risque
comment qu'ils nous prennent pas pour
pour la femme de service pour qu'ils ne
prennent pas seulement pour la mère de
ses enfants
personne même époque autre génération
les témoignages de grand mère montre que
les critères du partenaire parfait ont
bien évolué et que j'anime qu'avait la
santé et du travail
c'était beau figurez pas en 1991
d'après un sondage pour le magazine elle
les françaises rêve d'un homme plutôt
bras sportif drôle papa poule bonne
nécessairement riche et s'il avait fallu
l'incarner ça aurait été par jean hugues
anglade trouve ça très surprenant bof
bof c'est à la fois ça m'enchante et en
2019 une large étude a été menée auprès
de 64 mille femmes de 180 pays
et voici ce qu'elle attende 90% en
veulent de la gentillesse de la part
d'un homme aussi du soutien pour 86 5 %
des interrogés de l'intelligence pour 72
3%
la preuve d'un besoin de bienveillance
[Musique]
oh